hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for it is the
one you have been requesting as soon as
it finished round two of Qatar Masters
it is a a gentleman who just got his
grandmas title in 2023 from Kazakhstan
Alish sharov versus the highest rated
player in the world Magnus Carlson and
there is only uh one word that I can use
to describe this game and that is
moresque there is no other word I would
use to describe this uh this is how I
imagine a game uh if if they
like if they made a movie about Paul
morphy coming back to life and they
introduce him to 2023 and they say this
dude is Magnus Carlson go go beat him up
in chess and if morphe played the
absolute best game he ever played uh you
know U also that it's precise you know
I'm not talking about the Opera House
game or or something like that uh but
this would be the game that they use for
that so it's uh really brilliant I know
you guys are very much interested in how
precise everything is how How well was
it played uh it's very very precise by
both players but um well you already
know what happened so I'm just going to
show you the game so alisher suan has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to D4 Magnus goes for Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to C4 we have E6 and now Knight
to F3 and pawn to B6 Magnus goes for the
Queen's Indian defense not afraid of um
uh you know the boogeyman so of say
because ever since Alpha zero showed us
that those games against the Queens
Indian defense uh no one's been really
playing it at at the absolute highest
level but Magnus wants to use it as a
surprise here uh and now the main line
is G3 but we have Pawn to A3 and now
Magnus plays Bishop to A6 so this is
again a very standard move in the
Queen's Indian defense uh you want to
prevent um white from doing whatever
white wants like white can no longer
play something like G3 because the C4
Pawn is hanging so you have to defend it
with Queen to C2 or E3 and only then
will the bishop come back to B7 so this
is what happens we have Queen to C2
Bishop to B7 and Knight Knight to C3 so
these are all very well-known moves
nothing new Here pawn to C5 by Magnus
and pawn to E4 alisher grabs the full
Center we have C captures on D4 Knight
captures and Bishop to C5 going after
the Knight here so Knight back to F3 and
now Knight to C6 okay alisher loses the
tempo with bringing the Knight back to
F3 but Magnus will also lose a Tempo uh
moving the bishop once again so Pawn to
B4 uh strongest move in any position and
Bishop back to E7 we have Bishop to B2
and now there are some games where D6
was played but Magnus goes Queen to B8
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game now obviously
Magnus has great plans for this queen on
on B8 but uh once you see how the game
goes uh people might question this move
in the future uh Rook to D1 first not uh
bothering with the development of the
light Square bishop and castling quickly
to saf the first Rook to D1 uh also you
want to stop moves like Pawn to D5 and
now castles we have Bishop to E2 and now
Pawn to D6 we have castles and Rook to e
uh Rook to C8 so now aligning The Rook
nicely with the White Queen on C2 Rook F
to E1 and now Magnus plays Bishop to f8
so both now uh alisher already uh
developed all of his pieces he will
bring the bishop over to F1 so The Rook
nicely controls the file and Magnus
still has to figure out how to get this
Rook into the game so probably he has
some ideas of maybe opening up the
position trading one one Rook then
moving the queen then again the other
look into the game maybe trading that
Rook along the dile uh something like
that but KN after Bishop to f8 and
Bishop to F1 he plays Knight to E7 and
okay he wants to bring the Knight to G6
it will be a much better Square than C6
for the moment and now Knight to B5 as
the D6 Pawn is now undefended while the
Knight is here and you could play
something like Knight to G6 but then you
allow the doubling of the pawns with
Bishop captures on F6 but this is not
bad for black or anything black can very
very easily play this however Magnus
played Knight to E8 he doesn't want to
allow the doubling of his Pawn so he
defends everything H but now comes uh
Knight to G5 and okay looks like uh you
know a casual move some E5 ideas in the
future might uh you might run into
Checkmate so it's very natural to stop
this Magnus plays Knight to G6 stops in
E5 ideas and also the bishop now helps
out with the defense of the D6 Pawn so
everything seems very nicely defended uh
but the truth of the matter is uh Magnus
his position is already dead lost
Believe It or Not uh there is one move
that completely shatters his position
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on looking
for that one move that you know morphe
would go for and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to E5 the move that was made impossible
is actually very much possible and now
how do you deal with this move it looks
so weird what does it actually do I mean
you block your own dark Square
Bishop what does it do well for one it
opens up the Queen's diagonal once again
you are attacking that H7 Pawn but
what's the real point the real point is
that if black captures let's say if
Magnus captures Pawn captures on E5
Bishop captures on E5 attacks the queen
and the Knight of course cannot capture
because you get checkmated on H7 so how
would you defend this there's no defense
here you could block with the Knight
let's say you play Knight to C7 then
comes Rook to D7 piling up on the Knight
here and once F6 is played now look at
this Knight captures on H7 completely uh
destroying Black's position King Capt
you don't have to capture but you don't
have a move here King captures and now
Bishop captures and C7 Rook captures
Knight captures and now uh okay what
what do you play uh White will capture
The Rook on A8 if you uh try something
let's say you go Bishop to C6 you go
after the Rook here Rook move to F7 and
if Bishop to D6 now going for some
tricks to maybe attack the white king
you don't care about that you just play
Bishop to D3 go after the Knight the
Knight cannot move and once the Knight
is captured for example Bishop captures
you will play Bishop captures on G6 and
after King to h8 uh even Rook captures
on E6 capturing on H2 doesn't really
change anything mag um alisher can just
move the king and after you play
something well your Bishop here is
saying you don't really have a move uh
just Rook to E7 followed by captures and
G7 and there's no escaping this so E5
cannot be captured so D captures on E5
is not a move another move that Magnus
could play is Bishop to E7 he could go
after the Knight on G5 but now we go
Knight captures on F7 and after King
captures on F7 e captures on D6 now the
bishop is hanging also D7 is coming so
what can you play here let's see who
capture the pawn Knight captures on D6
uh Rook captures on E6 sacrificing a
full Rook Rook I mean I'm I'm at a loss
for words here and uh again now the
Knight is hanging so what what can you
play you have to capture the The Rook on
E6 other moves don't really help you and
now Pawn to C5 clearing the C4 Square
for the for the light Square Bishop B
captures on C5 Bishop to C4 with check
King to D7 Queen to F5 with check and
now after King to E8 Knight captures on
D6 with check Bishop captures seems like
you've saved the position but Queen F7
check King to d8 and now it's actually a
forced Checkmate starting with Bishop
captur on G7 freeing up the F6 Square
for the bishop so Bishop captures on G7
Knight to E7 and now Bishop to F6
threatening Checkmate as the bishop
cannot move from The Rook on the E file
sorry on the D file and after Queen to
C7 it doesn't really matter just Queen
to E6 going for Rook captures on E6 and
if you try to put a bishop here try to
give back some material doesn't really
matter just Rook captures and after the
bishop blocks Queen Capt after sun E7
will be Checkmate so after E5 you cannot
capture and you cannot ignore it Bishop
to E7 Bishop to E7 the line that we've
just saw uh is the top move recommended
by the engine so even with the top
engine defense you just get completely
obliterated so Magnus tried Pawn to D5
uh but now comes uh Queen to B3 I know
you guys are wondering what's the top
engine recommendation for white here the
top I will just show it the top
recommendation is Pawn four uh point
being that uh again uh that you cannot
play a move here for black there are
moves but all of them fail miserably uh
with tactics like if you attack the
knight uh Pawn to F5 that's the idea
behind Pawn to F4 and if he captures on
F5 you will play Knight captures on F7
now the king cannot capture as Queen
captures an F5 checks the king and picks
up the Knight here so you will play
Knight E7 but now Knight F to D6 and I
mean look you you can't find the move
for black if Rook to C6 your Rook is
hanging also by the way if Rook to C6
Knight captures an F5 and now if Queen
Queen to C8 trying to activate the queen
going after the queen on C2 and the
Knight on F5 uh you will play Bishop to
D3 and after Knight captures an F5
Bishop captures you will play Rook
captures and C4 trying to give back some
material H but now look at this bishop
captures and C8 Rook captures and C2
Bishop captures on B7 Rook captures on
B2 check on B2 but now Bishop captures
on D5 with check first king to h8 and
Bishop captures on A8 leaves um alisher
up a full Rook so not going to happen so
I'm I'm sure you guys were wondering
what uh what does the engine recommend
here but he doesn't go for that he plays
Queen to B3 and now his next move is uh
the the one that of course you are
looking at the entire game Magnus plays
Bishop to E7 if he can somehow activate
his pieces it' be great but Knight
captures on F7 uh he just can't catch a
catch a break here King captures on F7 C
captures on D5 now what do you play if
you try running away with the King then
comes D6 attacks the bishop and after
Bishop f8 Queen captures on E6 check and
after King to h8 just Bishop to D3 and
once the Knight is captured there's
nothing here if you don't allow that
other misfortunes will come your way
let's say you you you play something
then just Bishop captures Pawn captures
and Rook E3 there's no stopping Rook to
H3 Checkmate so uh you can't really uh
try to escape with the king so Bishop
captures on D5 was played attacking the
queen and here it's almost as if Magnus
survives but of course alisher will will
continue the attack with Rook captures
on D5 of course you have to do this
Magnus has to capture Queen captures on
D5 with check King to f8 and now Knight
to
D4 uh the most precise way of winning of
course that Knight to E6 check will be
deadly forcing the king under the mask
of the queen and uh if you go uh the the
one move that I thought Knight to C7
could prevent this as it attacks the
queen and also prevents Knight to E6 FS
to Queen to F3 with check and now after
King to G8 there's Knight to C6 I mean
this is absolutely disgusting attacking
the queen and now the only square is
Queen B7 Knight captures on E7 with
check winning the black queen on B7 so
after D4 Knight to D4 Magnus stried
Knight to F4 attacking Alisha's Queen
here but he just played Queen to F3 puts
pressure on the Knight here Magnus
gladly gives back some material in order
to survive this queen captures on F4 and
now Queen to B7 finally activating the
queen uh but Knight to F5 and and okay
Magnus now has a move he's not getting
checkmated in the next move but where is
the move what can he play if he plays
something active like Rook C2 attacks
the bishop prepares to bring the Rook
into the game already Bishop to A6 is
coming you can't move the the the queen
otherwise Knight A7 followed by check
and then Queen to f8 Checkmate uh and if
you move the queen queen to C7 now look
at this queen F3 attacks the rook and if
you save that Rook then Queen to B3
check will pick up this Rook on C2 so
there's really not I mean you could play
play Rook to Rook to d8 but Knight
captures on E7 uh misplaces the queen
from the defense of the Rook on C2 and
after the queen captures Queen to B3
check will pick up sorry we'll pick up
the Rook on C2 so this game is H is a
tactical headache one big tactical
headache Magnus played Pawn to B5 hoping
to now play Rook to C4 and then double
up Rooks on the C file uh but alisher of
course just plays Bishop captures on B5
the queen is stuck guarding the bishop
on E7 so Bishop to f8 and now Bishop to
C4 with check King to h8 and now a lot
of moves are winning here but alisher
goes for the cleanest solution Knight to
H6 and he was in this position on move
31 that Magnus Carlson resigned the game
is there is nothing more to be done here
so this is uh I mean this is an absolute
master class this is a you know a True
Modern attacking brilliancy this this
game is so moresque I don't remember the
last time I've seen such a game uh these
were only some of the lines I've shown
you I mean I've only show you like the
the really kill killer lines you could
you could show like
100 more lines and they' all be
incredible so I don't know whether I
plays this you know there's a video I
made Magnus Carlson's greatest loss it's
a game he played against leevon arunan
where leevon completely obliterated him
but this was like playing this was like
you know playing morphe in his own era
there was nothing you could do morphe
was so dominant I mean look at the
finishing position the Knight on H6
Queen on F4 uh the bishop PA from Hell
attacking your king now this uh well uh
definitely does not look like a game
Magnus Carlson played with the black
pieces but he did try the Queen's Indian
defense what are you going to do uh you
know not not maybe the greatest of
choices and uh yeah here you resign
because if you capture the Knight then
just Queen captures an f8 his Checkmate
as we've said in the outer lines the
Knight disconnects the Rooks and look at
this if you play Knight to C7 okay now
the Rooks are connected also the bishop
is defended now comes the real threat
Queen to F7 threatening Checkmate on G8
and if you move the bishop uh anywhere
where it doesn't really matter you could
capture the B4 Pawn as that's a really
strong Pawn uh of course you run into
Queen to G8 check and after the queen is
captured Knight to F7 a beautiful
smattered Checkmate so this game
contains everything it contains all the
tactics all the tricks from you know
throughout chess history uh and you know
uh with with the possibly the greatest
chess player who ever lived on the
receiving and of this uh you know big
stick so absolutely incredible and this
is I'm sure you guys are interested W
Magnus wrote on his Twitter page after
this game was played so he said that I
was completely crushed in my game today
this is not to accuse my opponent of
anything who played an amazing game and
deserved to win but honestly as soon as
I saw my opponent was wearing a watch
early in the game I lost my ability to
concentrate I obviously take
responsibility for my inability to deal
with those thoughts properly uh but it's
also incredibly frustrating to see
organizers still not taking
anti-cheating seriously at all all no
transmission delay Spectators walking
around the playing Hall with smartphones
uh and so on so that's what Magnus uh
said after the game he did congratulate
his opponent but he also said that he
was very much frustrated with the
organizers as uh you know uh I don't
know what kind of a watch was it I doubt
it was an analog watch maybe it was like
a smart watch or something uh but still
if it's allowed uh you know you know
it's allowed if if it's not allowed it
shouldn't be allowed but um yeah I I
don't know I'm going to treat this as an
actual morphes brilliancy miniature
because okay it's 31 moves is maybe not
considered a miniature but against
Magnus Carlson it is most definitely
considered a miniature so there we have
it that's the game hope you hope you
guys enjoyed it big congratulations to
alisher sanov like I said he he achieved
his grandmas title in 2023 and already
uh played possibly one of the possibly
the greatest game ever against Magnus
it is this is not a baby Magnus or
like a 17-year-old Magnus this is a you
know fully evolved Magnus cars this is
this is his final form uh and he just
gets crushed like this do do with what
you will incredible game I'm very happy
that it happened you know uh as it's is
beautiful so you know hope you enjoyed
it as well uh so that's the game I
really hope you enjoyed it uh I would
like to thank Roger Stone no need to
mention me in the video Douglas Hooper m
3 Pat and Nathan Gibson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day